Okay, perfect.
Hey, how are you?
Hey, Jack. Good morning. I'm good. How about yourself?
Yeah, I'm doing well. Good to meet you.
Same here.
Awesome, guys. Are we waiting on anybody else or are going to be the three of us here today?
Fortunately or unfortunately, it's just going to be a three of us.
So you'll have to bear with our faces for the upcoming half an hour.
No worries. No worries.
Well, perfect, guys. Are we okay on time? Do you guys have a hard stop to at the 30 minute mark or?
Yeah, unfortunately, I do.
Okay. Awesome. Well, yeah, I think this should give us plenty of time, at least for today's conversation.
And I guess what I was thinking for today, in terms of an agenda,
feel free to add kind of whatever you want to bake in.
But obviously on my end, we'd kind of love to get a little bit of a better insight into kind of your roles within the org, right?
What maybe your familiarity level is with Crossbeam.
And then on my side, happy to dive into it, clear up any questions, right?
Spend some time in the platform as well, if it's helpful.
I know how to chance to kind of look inside your guys' account.
It looks like we're kind of still getting set up.
So I want to make sure I can clear up any questions there.
But does that work for you guys in terms of an agenda?
Yeah, that does.
Okay. Great. Well, yeah, I'd love to kick it over to you.
I've kind of done some research just kind of on short hills.
But do you mind just kind of giving me some background too on your guys' roles and kind of how you fit into the team?
Sure. So, I want to decide.
I look over the entire partnership ecosystem over here at Short Hills.
We've been with the firm for almost a year at this point of time.
Short Hills is primarily a gendered-to-be-ai, origin-to-be-ai services.
We're a services firm.
And we have partnered up with Databricks for the last couple of years now.
At this point of time, we have grown our partnership to quite a good level with Databricks.
And they recommended Crossbeam to us.
And I was like, why don't we get started with leveraging Crossbeam to just see what is happening inside our systems and coordinate for going forward for our sales motion.
Perfect. And I did see that PartnerPass come over through Databricks.
I know it's primarily, it sounds like it's Databricks that's pushing the setup with Crossbeam.
I think you guys have some pretty strong partnerships with a few other organizations, right?
Maybe Snowflake, a couple others to name a few.
Is there a desire to potentially get connections with a few other partners?
Two, or is it really just Databricks that's driving it now?
As of right now, it's just Databricks.
I'm not very familiar with the platform Crossbeam, to be very honest.
I just know that it is kind of a CRM integration system which would integrate with our CRM with Databricks' CRM.
Apart from that, I don't have any information on what exactly Crossbeam is able to do, how to actually even utilize it.
So I shot forward the connection request and I accepted it.
And that's why we're here.
Just to understand how Crossbeam actually works and whether it makes sense for us to go all in with Crossbeam, link it up with different partners that we have like Microsoft, AWS and Snowflake.
Okay.
Yeah, perfect.
And again, we could spend some time on the platform too and kind of the background, how you get set up right, what the CRM connection would look like.
I think you're thinking about it the right way.
I think the way I think about Crossbeam really is like a window into your partner CRMs, right?
So yeah, getting partnership connection with Databricks, whatever other partner you might look to get facilitated.
And where I think about it to start is unearthing open opportunities, prospects, customers.
Like those are our three default overlaps that you'll be able to see.
However, you can get very granular with the data that you want to be able to show.
And that's ultimately just depending on what you guys can figure as data sharing and also what Databricks is willing to share as well.
So a nice way to think about it.
I guess with maybe this initial use case with Databricks is the goal to like develop more of like a true co-sell motion or is it really to kind of drive more pipeline?
What's maybe the goal that you're envisioning with this from the partnership's end?
A mix of both of the points that you just mentioned.
So it is to the end goal for us is obviously to drive sales to get more revenue at the end of the day.
Now it just depends on how we can do that.
One option is to go forward with, hey, this is my account that I'm already working with.
How do we collaborate for this particular account?
The other one is, hey, we are looking to break into this account.
Do you have any sort of connection over there?
So mix of sales strategy plus a GDM strategy.
Okay.
Yeah, super helpful.
And I guess to just have an understanding on kind of how things are being done now.
When you are sharing some of this data, say with Databricks, for example, is it really just like corresponding via like spreadsheets or how are you sharing data with them currently?
We're not sharing any data with them.
So we are just having communication via Zoom calls or via Teams call, trying to understand, hey, this is the work that we are doing at this point of time in this particular account.
Are you also engaged in this particular account?
Can we sort of collaborate?
So they have a deal registration portal.
We have communication with different AEs and that's how we're building out the relationship.
But we're looking to take it from in a much more formalized direction and how we can establish a closer relationship and take it forward.
Okay.
Super helpful.
Do you work closely too with like the sales award?
Would we be looking to kind of equip our sales rep potentially with this data, right?
To drive more pipeline, drive more revenue, like you mentioned, right?
Or is it first to start with you and the partnerships team?
Maybe you share that data with them.
Again, just trying to understand maybe how you guys would leverage it.
I have not gone through the platform.
So I really don't know the capabilities.
I'm just exploring at this point of time how it actually works.
How can I actually integrate it with my dynamic system and how to take it forward?
Got it.
And I think you just mentioned it there from a CRM perspective.
Are you guys leveraging dynamics or what CRM are you using?
Okay.
And we're also looking to have a custom CRM solution that we have created.
So that might come up at a later point of time, but right now dynamics.
Okay.
That's something you guys are building out internally.
Yeah.
We have almost filled it out.
Now it's in the testing phase.
Okay.
Got it.
Super helpful.
Well, perfect.
Yeah.
I think again, appreciate the insight.
Right.
It's helpful for me too, just to kind of see where you guys are at and ultimately maybe
how you'd look to use the tool as well.
I guess for some of the remaining time that we have left, would it be helpful to kind of dive into
cross beam and kind of look at the platform and kind of walk through maybe just a quick demo?
Sure.
That looks great.
Okay.
Perfect.
Let me start sharing my screen here for us.
I just started sharing here.
Can you see my screen?
Okay.
Yeah.
It's good.
Okay.
Perfect.
So this is going to be the cross beam web application, right?
If you've logged in, if you've accepted the invite from Databricks, you've maybe seen something similar.
I actually have your account up right here, right?
So this is what you guys have configured now.
I'm going to kind of walk through what this is going to look like once we have a data source
configured, right?
Once we have everything set up properly, when I jump back to my account here, right, the
left-hand side panel, this is going to be kind of your control panel.
There's a number of different areas that you're going to be able to access within cross beam.
The first place you get brought to is this partner list though, right?
So once we have partnerships connected, once we have a data source set up, here's where
you're going to live.
Ultimately, there's a couple of different ways you can use the data to.
Of course, you can use the web app here or moving forward if you wanted to be able to have this
live directly within Dynamics and just be able to view overlap data and partnership information
through cross beam in Dynamics.
That's another way that we can look at it.
Let's take, right, if I just want to look at one of my partners here, let's use Bazzala,
for example, right?
Let's say Bazzala's Databricks in this example.
When I click into this, that matrix that I was kind of hinting at earlier in terms of
the default data that we're going to be able to see with our partner is customers, open
opportunities and prospects.
Your data is going to live across the left hand side.
Your partner's data is going to live across the top.
So this is going to be Databricks information here.
Really valuable for me, right?
If I kind of put my seller hat on, typically where I'm going to live is like my prospect data
compared to where my partner is already doing business, right?
So if I wanted to map out my prospects against Databricks as customers, I've got 106 overlaps here.
I'm going to be able to click into this data and see all those prospect accounts.
And I'm also going to be able to see the account rep over at Databricks, right?
So it sounds like you guys are kind of hopping on Zooms now, right?
You're walking through, you're seeing where's opportunity.
Now potentially, right?
I mentioned yourself or your reps, right?
If we want to equip the reps with this data, they could reach out directly to that Databricks
individual, right?
Maybe facilitate an introduction this way.
So first off, you're going to be able to see overlaps.
This is kind of step one.
Any questions thus far though, just on the matrix that I was just in, right?
How do I establish the communication?
I have not done the dynamics integration.
That is question number one.
Question number two is how, I mean, what sort of information would be shared?
How much of the information would be shared?
And question number three, what is the pricing structure that we are looking at?
Yeah, no good questions.
I think, yeah, taking a step back to if we want to look at like data source connection
and how we get set up and ultimately what you're able to share.
A lot of that is.
customizable. So if I go down here into data, right, step one is going to be getting a data
source connected, right? In my example, I have Salesforce configured, that's our core CRM. But
for you guys, right, we'd walk through the dynamics setup, right? We'd select dynamics as a data source.
Depending on the populations that you want to set up, right, a lot of this is customizable. If I'm
going to minimize this for an example, when I click into Salesforce here, we have some field
presets that are recommended, right, based on like what we want to be able to see right off the
bat, right, customer list, prospect list, open opportunities, depending on how you have that
defined a dynamics, oftentimes these will map out automatically to that. But if you wanted to get
very custom and come in here and map this out directly, or if you wanted to, if I minimize
this and I come into my populations, right, maybe you don't want to share some of your
open opportunities, or you don't want to share specific customers, you can absolutely do that,
right, just keep in mind, Databricks has the same capability, right? So in terms of what data is
able to be shared here, you can get very granular. Again, it's ultimately just kind of on your guys's
end and a preference in terms of what you'd want to have shown. Yeah. But yeah, I think step one
for us right is actually if we come back to your account here, emergency, looks like we just have
git set up as a data source. So connecting a data source, we'd walk through the steps here,
right, you could choose a CRM, it's going to give you some step by step instructions and I can pass
along some documentation here. I guess question for you, Manchu, do you guys have like a dynamics
admin that you'd want to have maybe go through this or is this something that you'd be willing to do
as well? I would send it forward to the dynamics admin, he will take care of whatever linking is
required. Okay. Yeah, and I think on that note, I think I like to tell customers because they
oftentimes have questions around like set up, right? I mean, it's really straightforward, typically
people can have it done in like 20 to 30 minutes, especially you ever really saw an understanding
of your dynamic setup, which I'm assuming this individual does. So not really a big lift here.
Again, it would just want to be mindful in terms of data sharing and what you want to have populated,
but again, I have some best practices guides there and I'm happy to push that over too.
Sure. If you could share some details with me, that will actually help me out
pass that information to my dynamics admin and he can take things forward from there.
Emergency. Okay. Yeah, 100%. I think when we hop off the conversation here, I'll make sure I pass.
Everything, what are you doing here? Yeah, there's an alarm, right? Can you hear that? I'm working from
home at the moment and I think there's a test alarm going off. So I apologize. No, I thought
there was an emergency going on. I didn't want to hold you back. No, no, it's a test, I believe. So
yeah, I apologize. I thought it wouldn't be going through my AirPods here, but I know it's pretty loud.
Great. Yeah, hopefully if anything does happen, I might need to step away, but I think it's just
a test. Awesome. So again, the data setup stuff, I'll pass over some documentation there and I'll
get that over to you at the end of the conversation here. I think going back to just best practices
on like once we have a data source connected, how we best leverage the tool, if I jump back into my
account here, typically where I live, right, if I go back to put my seller hat on is going to be
these three areas on the left hand side. So account mapping, pipeline generation, and deal
navigator, account mapping. Sorry, looks like the test is done. So my account mapping here, right,
these are going to map out accounts based on where you already have overlaps, right, where your
partners are already doing business. For you guys to start, if we're only looking to have
Databricks set up here, right, this will be a lot more simplistic, but you'll be able to see.
AWS, Microsoft and Snowflake also leverage this platform, Crossbeam.
Correct. Got it. Yep, Snowflake, 100% too. So we have a very strong partnership with them,
if that's a desire here, right? Yeah. This is I want to stabilize the Databricks team,
so I would rather focus on that right now. Okay. Yeah, no, totally fair. And I think if we wanted
to look at like a crawl walk run approach, right, with some of these additional partners, 100%,
but yeah, if the goal is to start with Databricks, we can certainly start there.
But yeah, I think like account mapping, right, like it's going to give me a recommended partner.
And what we mean by this is like, we have a really high win rate, right, when the last
opportunity they closed, how closely aligned is this partnership? So we got some data here.
For you, I think you mentioned the main goal was like pipeline generation, right,
and how we just boost overall revenue. We live in this pipeline generation section here. So think
of pipeline generation, these are going to be prospect accounts. So whatever you have defined
as a prospect living in dynamics, you can obviously get more granular too. If you were like, Hey,
show me my top tier prospects, you can filter this out and get pretty creative. But take
Palomar here, for example, right, this is a prospect account of mine. I know that Bazzala,
Holver, in your instance, it's going to be Databricks, right? They're already doing business
with them. Going to give me some insight into why and then deal navigator. This will be open
opportunities. So let's say survey pal here, for example, I've got an open up with them.
It's stuck in stage three or stage four, right? Maybe I want to tap in Databricks. I want to
tap in the Databricks rep over there, right? Hey, who was the economic buyer within this deal,
right? Any insight you can share with me on this prospect account here, you can do that with the
deal navigator. Again, I know I'm moving quickly. Let me pause for a second. Any questions on kind
of these three areas I just walked through? No, I'm good for now. Awesome. Is this kind of what
you were envisioning too, when you kind of got the data or excuse me, the past from Databricks?
Is this making sense? I was just wondering if I share all of my prospects, say I'm just interacting
with or I've just had first level conversation with them. I'm looking to double click on them,
work together with them, and see if Databricks is also engaged in that particular account.
Maybe Databricks is also looking at that account as a prospect. So would that be visible over here
and where would that show up? So that's going to come back to our matrix here. So if we're both
looking at prospect accounts, that's going to live here. So prospects for you and prospects for
Databricks, that would live in here. So we're going prospect first prospect. We can see that here.
And then we can open the account and we can see maybe where else other partners are living
within some of these. So if we did look to get AWS or Microsoft moving forward in the future and we
know, hey, there are already customers of this prospect account, you can see that. Any opportunities
potentially that they may have had. So we can see open ops. And then we also got contact level
data. So we can see, hey, Maria here, she's obviously a top tier person at site.
Is it LinkedIn for this is linked with some other solution.
This is linked with cross beam. And what I mean by that is cross beam showing like what account data
was used when this individual account was doing business with another partner, right? So I know
that like Lee and nutman here is a top persona that I need to get in contact with at this prospect
account. We're going to show you like the account. We're not necessarily going to give you phone
number, email, right? Like we could get you email if it's from the partner level, but on the prospect
level, we won't show you that data. But yeah. So yeah, prospect to prospect, we can see that here.
I think really where cross beam starts to become very valuable is when we're pushing this information
directly to dynamics. So for you guys, right, depending on maybe how you work, Manchu, maybe
depending on how your reps like to work. So again, I'm going to use Salesforce, for example,
because that's the CRM that I leverage. But if I'm just under an account record here,
say survey pal, right, let's say this is a top prospect account that you guys have living in
dynamics. Once we have, depending on the version of cross beam that you're on, we can start to pull
this data directly into CRM. So now you'll be able to see the overlap data here under an account
record, right? We know, hey, in this example for you guys, it'd be Databricks, they're a customer,
who the partner rep is over there. We've also got this cross beam co pilot. And this is essentially
bringing in the cross beam UI directly to CRM. So this co pilot, this could live directly within
your dynamics CRM instance as well. So for yourself, your reps, they can come in here and see,
obviously Databricks is going to be a top partner to work with who the individual is over here.
And I can get that contact level data. So essentially, we're going to know based on the
prior engagement that Databricks had with this account that Braden Russo, he was the economic
buyer for survey pal, right? He was somebody that was very vital in getting the deal done. I know
from my perspective, right, when I'm looking to break into survey pal, that I got to get in touch
with Braden here. So a couple of different ways we can look at accessing the data and ultimately
where it could live as well. Any questions on kind of this piece, right? And ultimately what
the vision could look like within CRM directly, right? And yeah, in your guys's instance, that
would be dynamics. No, I would need to explore it a little bit to understand.
and more about what we can really do
and what is really available.
And I need to get in touch with my dynamics admin
as well to understand, hey, how can we do the linking?
Okay, yeah, I think like next steps from here,
I think goal number one would be
get the setup documentation over to you,
get that share with your dynamics admin as well.
I think on our end, I'm happy to have a conversation
with that dynamics individual as well.
If they have some questions, particularly around setup,
if we wanna go through like an enablement walkthrough,
just to make sure we've got your account
configured properly.
And then maybe once we have the data source configured,
we could do another session ride on like,
hey, how do we action on the overlap data
we're now seeing with Databricks inside cross beam?
Happy to do that.
Sure.
Is this something in terms of setup
that you guys think you'll have the bandwidth to do,
like over the next couple of weeks,
or like from a timeline perspective,
what are you kind of looking at?
I'm looking at completing the setup
for the communication within this week.
And then I'll have a musician,
then I'll take a look at what exactly
is the data that is being pulled in,
how does it look like,
and how do you want to take it forward?
Okay, perfect.
So I think in terms of maybe like a next step for us,
maybe once we've got the data source setup this week,
maybe we look at like same time or early next week
as kind of a secondary conversation to walk through,
maybe how we action on the data from here.
Sure.
Let me first have the connector setup.
Let me first have all of the things slender
and then maybe we can have the follow up on the session.
Okay.
Yeah, no, I'm happy to do that.
Maybe I can kind of shoot over some times too,
that might work best,
and we can look to get something scheduled.
But yeah, I think let me push over
the setup documentation to you.
I'll make sure I get that over here,
send over an email shortly.
And then, yeah, I think looking at your account,
I'm just wanna make sure here I've got it
right in front of me.
It looks like you're the only individual setup
within the account right now.
It's very easy to add a user.
So if you wanna be able to add that dynamics admin
to Crossbeam so they can walk through setup,
you can just push them and invite directly
through the Crossbeam portal.
Sure, blue card.
Okay.
Again, I know we've got to bounce around a bit.
Any other questions for me, anything you think we're missing
or?
No, I think we should be good for now.
So what do we really get at this point of time
to start off with, what do we really get?
How do we, what are the number of seats that we have?
What are the communications that we can set up?
What exactly will be offered that is available to us
right now with Crossbeam?
Good question.
So let me go back to sharing my screen.
So I'm in your account right now,
right, you can get two other individuals in here,
right on the free version.
So again, it sounds like we're gonna get
the dynamics individual added,
maybe one other team member built in here on the free tier.
We'll walk through the, if I go back to data, right,
we'll make sure we get dynamics set up as a data source
and we'll just step through that here
in the account setup at the top.
I think a couple of things to point out right off the bat
that you'll have access to on the free version.
So with this account mapping pass from Databricks,
you'll be able to see those overlaps that I highlighted,
right, so customers open opportunities in prospects.
If you wanted to get more granular, right,
if you wanted to-
I'm gonna get all of that for all of my prospects
and all of my customers or just open opportunities,
what will I get?
So I'd have to double check with what Databricks
has set on their sharing settings.
I believe they share all three,
but I'm not 100% positive.
So I'll need to double check with the Databricks rep
here on the cross-bue mend to just confirm.
But yes, once we have your data source set up
and the data's flowing in from Dynamics,
you'll be able to see these three overlaps.
If one of these you'd like to restrict, right,
depending on data setup, again,
if you wanna maybe lock down open opportunities,
you could do that.
Again, just a setting that you'd have to configure
on the data setup side.
Got it.
And how many, so is there a limit on the number
of line items that would be there?
For example, I have at this point of time,
say a hundred or 200 odd accounts that I have stored up
in my CRM.
For those 200 accounts, I have maybe say 10
prospects linked out for each particular account.
By account, I have to do a prospect name.
And then the details would be the person to each other,
POC.
Good question.
So I'm gonna jump back to my account here
so we can look at this.
But yeah, so limitations on the free version, right?
Let's, like you mentioned,
let's say you have a hundred overlaps here with Databricks,
you're only gonna be able to see 50.
So that is a limitation on the free tier.
If you had 150, you'd have access to 50.
But then once you eclipse the 50, this will be grayed out.
And that's again, just the limitation on the free tier.
Can we filter out which ones we want to see in the 50
or it would be by default?
It'll be by default.
Got it.
Another thing too,
just as you're getting more familiar with crossbeam,
so like pipeline generation deal navigator here,
when I click into these,
you'll only be able to see the first 10.
Once we eclipse 10, they also get grayed out.
So just another limitation on the free tier,
I think to start right, I mean, it's great.
So pipeline is the ones we have jointly integrated
or the ones that I am pursuing
and they are also pursuing.
What exactly is, are you referring to this?
Yeah, so pipeline, right?
This is gonna be prospect accounts
based on where your partners are already doing business.
So your prospects are a customer of Databricks.
So it'll map it out here.
Yeah, so same goes for the account mapping piece here.
You'd only see 10 and same goes for deal navigator.
So just keep that in mind
as we're first initially getting set up.
Moving forward to if the goal is to start
to bring crossbeam data into Dynamics, right?
Like the overlap data here, the co-pilot,
these are only accessible on paid versions of crossbeam.
You would not have access to that on the free tier.
Got it.
And I'm happy to share some information too
around pricing if it's helpful.
We can maybe walk through kind of a pricing conversation too
on like a potential next call from here.
We've got two different tiers from our free tier.
The next version up is what we call connector.
The next version from there is called super node.
So connector starts at $4,800 a year
and then depending on seats,
you could add a per seat cost from there essentially.
And that's essentially just who you'd want
to have access to crossbeam.
That unlocks the co-pilot in Dynamics.
If you wanted to have the Dynamics co-pilot,
you can use it to have the bi-directional sync with CRM
where data is automatically flowing back
into Dynamics from crossbeam that requires super node.
Got it.
And what about the connector and the super node?
What is the number of accounts that I can see
with both of them?
So in terms of like data unlocks,
connector unlocks pretty much all of them.
So especially if only considering data bricks
at this time, you'll be able to see all overlaps.
Certainly we'll be able to see all overlaps with super node.
Really the difference in those two
is that bi-directional sync,
but also the custom like record exports.
So if you're looking to export data,
I think with connector you get 5,000.
Super node you get 25,000.
Got it.
And Dynamics, if you could share this information as well
at least give me a direction to have a conversation
with my leadership team about how we can take it full.
Yeah, happy to.
I've got kind of a one pager that breaks down
core differences between connector and super node.
So I'll include that in my follow up as well.
And then yeah, when it comes to like potential pricing,
happy to have a conversation around that as well.
Sounds good.
All right.
I'll have to jump over.